-Last time you did our show,
we were --
It was the one week
we went afield of New York.
We went to Washington, D.C.,
and performed in the giant
Warner Theatre.
-Beautiful theater.
-And you said you were going to
have a very hard time coming
back to this little theater.
How is it so far?
-It's fine.
-Okay.
Thank you for being honest.
-You're welcome.
You know what?
I have to pee so bad.
And I decided
I'm not going to do it.
I'm going to use it.
-Oh.
-Because we're artists.
-Yeah.
-But it's really distracting.
-Oh, wow.
So, now looking back, you made
a mistake, would you say?
-I feel like I probably
should have done it.
It does only get worse.
-Yeah. Famously.
Yeah. It doesn't pass.
-I'm not going to, like,
stop things to pee. I'm fine.
If you had some kind of
wide-mouthed Snapple bottle,
I would do it right here.
-I don't. I don't.
-Anyway, go see
this children's movie.
-Okay.
-Sorry.
-Because I've heard you --
Obviously you have to
promote this movie
that is a wonderful movie
for children,
even though it deals
with serious themes.
But you were warned
during the first press tour
to remember that it was
a film for children.
-Well, "Wreck-It Ralph,"
that was the first one.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kidding, kidding.
So then we started promoting it.
And one day,
we went to Disneyland.
And we did a bunch --
It was a junket.
It wasn't like we were
at Soarin', you know?
And they take us
from room to room to room
to do junket interviews
with people.
So they kept drilling it
into me, you know,
just a reminder that
this is a children's movie
and blah, blah, blah,
and I'm like, "I get it.
I'm not, you know,
a monster or whatever."
And so I do the first interview,
and then they're walking me
to the next interview.
And on the walk,
the woman was like,
"Just want to remind you again,
it is a children's movie."
And I go, "You know what?
This is honestly insulting.
I'm a grown woman.
I certainly know the --
Yes, I work blue in my comedy,
but I certainly
know the difference."
And she goes, "Well,
in that interview, you just
said that Q-bert does coke."
And I was like, "I did?
I have no memory of that."
-It would make sense, though.
-It would make so much sense.
-Yeah.
He looks -- I feel like he's
built for it, Q-bert, right?
Doesn't Q-bert have -- Isn't he
just all just one long nose?
-Yeah. He's one long nose.
-Yeah.
-And then he's constantly
talking in inaudible...
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
This movie is --
You go from the video-game world
to the world of the Internet.
-Yeah.
-And it actually tackles themes
of the Internet in a way
that I think will be really
interesting for kids to see
that it is a wonderful place,
the Internet,
but also a terrifying place.
-100%.
And it's nice to reflect
the world that they
actually live in.
So, I mean, it's the Internet,
good and bad.
It's bombardment.
It builds you up.
It crushes you down.
And you start pinning your worth
on outside things.
And the only way to survive it
is to kind of look inward,
which is not just for kids,
but something that we all kind
of constantly need to learn.
And the bad guy in it
is not a bad guy.
It's just Ralph's
own insecurity.
It really -- I know
it's just a Disney movie.
But it's about
the human condition.
But I will admit, that's what
I've been saying in press.
And, really, you could just
say that about anything.
Everything's about
the human condition.
It just sounds smart.
It sounds very smart.
-On the Internet, you have
experienced both
the good and the bad.
I have always found it
incredibly commendable
and have been very impressed
with the fact
that sometimes you, when people
maybe will come at you
with negativity,
instead of blocking them,
you engage with them
with a level of empathy
that not a lot of people use
as a tool.
-I don't always do it.
It's a -- You know, I'm trying.
I'm not always my best self,
you know?
-Yeah.
-But, yeah.
When I feel like
it's a vulnerable --
To me, I see a big difference
between the liars
who I have no respect, patience,
and don't feel
I need to be open to...
and the lied-to,
whose crime is believing liars.
-Sure. Well, your show --
Your fantastic show on Hulu.
"I Love You, America."
-Nice.
-Obviously you used --
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You use that, as well.
-Yeah.
-Because now that wall
of social media
where you actually can't look
people in the eye is gone.
And have you found it rewarding
to talk to people that,
from the get-go, obviously have
a different worldview than you?
-Hugely.
I mean, I had a family dinner
with a family in Wyoming,
and they're conservative
Republicans.
And, you know, I think
when I'm flying there
and they're anticipating me,
we're filling our brains.
Your brain, like, fills in
what you don't know with
something that you do know.
And it's not accurate
until you're there, you know?
And I don't think we changed
each other's minds at all.
But we --
I left there loving them.
You know what I mean?
You go to Thanksgiving, and half
the people you don't agree with.
-Yeah. This is very exciting.
We've talked about this before.
We're from the same hometown,
a little place called
Bedford, New Hampshire.
And a dear friend
of my mother's,
who was your fifth-grade
teacher, Sue Mullen,
was elected to state office,
and the first Democrat in
I think over -- since the '40s.
-85 years.
To state legislature.
-And the first woman ever.
-The first woman ever.
Mind-boggling.
And she was your
fifth-grade teacher.
-Yeah, Mrs. Mullen.
-Do you have any
Sue Mullen memories?
-You know,
I don't remember this,
but she tells this story.
She, in fifth grade,
I guess asked me what I wanted
to be when I grew up.
And I said either
a scientist or a lesbian.
And I'm actually not attracted
to women personally,
but I thought it was a job
and it seemed easy.
-That seems like -- Fifth grade
seems old to get that wrong.
-I know. It was old, but...